die bilder von der absturzstelle im
mexikanischen bundesstaat durango lassen
schlimmes vermuten doch die passagiere
an bord der maschine der
fluggesellschaft aeromexico haben
offenbar glück im unglück gehabt bei dem
flugzeugabsturz am dienstag wurden zwar
mindestens 85 menschen verletzt es hat
aber wohl keine todesopfer gegeben und
das flugzeug habe etwa zehn kilometer
vom flughafen in durango entfernt eine
notlandung gemacht sagte ein sprecher
des örtlichen zivilschutzes im fernsehen
augenzeugen hätten von einem lauten
knall berichtet bevor die maschine zu
boden ging sagte der gouverneur der
provinz an bord der maschine befanden
sich den angaben zufolge mehr als 100
menschen
der flughafenbetreiber führte das
unglück auf schlechtes wetter zurück
kurz nach dem start sei die maschine von
einer windböe erfasst worden hieß es
die verletzten wurden zur behandlung ins
krankenhaus gebracht einige von ihnen
befinden sich in einem kritischen
zustand sagte der arzt sergio gonzalez
sie werden noch untersucht 25 von
denjenigen die wir haben haben keine
ernsten verletzungen auf der anderen
seite gibt es zehn personen deren
zustand ernst ist einer von ihnen muss
operiert werden
auch der pilot habe verbrennungen
erlitten und befinde sich in einem
ernsten zustand hieß es
alle passagiere samt crew hätten sich
aber retten können ehe das flugzeug
feuer gefangen habe